نعم زين العابدين الان نحاول اعاده رسم
هذا السيناريو الذي جاء عبر الاخبار
العاجله منذ قليل وكيف تمت هذه العمليه
بتسلسلها في البدايه المصدر في القسام قال
ان القوات المدافعه كانت تتمركز منذ
اسابيع هنا في الشرق
ال في المنطقه الغربيه مقارنه بالسياج اي
وذلك ظل مستمرا هذا التمركز والرصد ظل
مستمرا حتى رغم القصف الاسرائيلي المكثف
والذي كان يمهد في تلك المنطقه اذا هذه
كانت في المرحله الاولى الان كان هناك
تعليمات لهذه القوات الموجوده في هذه
المنطقه كما نشاهد هنا بلا تقوم باي
عمليه لتكشف مكان هذه القوات خلال تلك
المرحله وذلك ب انتظار اهداف وصفتها
بالثمين الان بعد هذه العمليه وعمليات
القصف بدات القوات بعض القوات تتوغل في
هذا الاتجاه كان هناك حقل الغام موجود
سابقا لكن مع توغل القوات الاسرائيليه
الاولى كانت التعليمات بعدم ال بعدم
الاشتباك مع هذه القوات بانتظار قوات اخرى
اكبر منها اذا عبور لحقل الالغام هذا
القوات تتقدم القوات الاسرائيليه القوات
المدافعه ما تزال في عمليه الرصد ومستمره
في مكانها وقد رافق هذه القوات ايضا
عمليات قصف متقدم هنا نلاحظ بان القوات
المدافعه يبدو انها كانت تتمركز في
مناطق جيده ل للحمايه من القصف المدفعي او
بالقصف بالطيران وهذا تكتيك ربما يجدر
ملاحظته خلال هذه المرحله الان هناك هنا
في مرحله الكمون الاستعداد
للقوات المهاجمه تجاوز مرحله القصف تجاوز
لمرحله التوغل بعد
ذلك بدات القوات الهندسيه قوات الهندسه
بالعبور هنا بدا التشخيص بان هذه القوات
يمكن الالتحام معها لكن ليس بعد هنا بدات
القوات بالوصول وصلت الى المباني بعد ان
وصلت هذه القوات الى المباني انتظرت القوه
التي الموجوده في مناطق الدفاع لتلغيم
المبنى كاملا بعد تلغيم المبنى تم استخدام
قذيفه التي بي جي او الار بي جي والتي
عملت وكانها محرض للتفجيرات الموجوده في
تلك المباني الان بعد ذلك ذلك قامت
العمليات هنا بوجود عمليات الانقاذ حاولت
عفوا استهداف للدبابه بعد ذلك هنا استهداف
لهذه
الدبابه التسلسل كان المبنى ثم
الدبابه بعد زرع التحريض ثم جاءت القوه
الراجله للاسعاف وهنا بدا تفجير عمليه حقل
الالغام ثم جاءت عمليات نجده كان هذا هو
التسلسل على الخريطه z